but i wanted to say i'm sorry what
you've been going through and it's been
really hard for us
oh yeah we're whole family i know you
know how you've been feeling
i feel a lot better since i came here
i'm not this room i mean came to l.a
yeah
you know i you know like free women now
you know yeah
because you're in phoenix by yourself
i'm not lonely i know but still
i i have to text you every night how can
i belong
you know i have to text him every night
every night and what he
uh respond nothing
so i asked him should i stop texting you
he goes
no mom i enjoy it but he never answered
to me
yeah at least the stupid say mom i love
you
well once he say mama i love you and he
said what's up you know but i
really don't know what job means yeah
and i
asked stephen you know uh your brother
say what so what what
what should i you know uh tell them i
tell him he goes
mom that's just asking you don't have to
say nothing
all right yeah what's up just hi hi
what's going on what's going on
you know in my mind i really don't
understand what's
what's up means yeah get up
oh yeah yeah yeah it doesn't make any
sense you know i don't like what's up
yeah like
yeah yeah what's up get up
yeah yeah what's up yeah or look yeah
i asked every americans you know what
what's your means
yeah because you just say it you know
whatever you want it you know but still
i don't understand a lot of english is
really to me it's really
what is the meaning of vogue i feel like
it's a fashion or like a dance
type of dance that's my i think vogue is
a yeah
i think it's a style of posing yes
possibly because madonna did the vogue
yeah yeah i think it's a it's a
it's a i don't think anyone knows what's
vocal nobody knows about it
so i don't have to feel bad you don't
have to feel better i study english
every day
yeah but a lot of words really i don't
understand you know
yeah but i've just been having a hard
time mom
what spanish
mama what was that i speak expensive
wow you've got all these skills that i'm
not even aware of
i have you know in my kitchen i have all
the
about uh english yeah spanish yeah
chinese chinese japanese oh and korean
you know oh she wants you want to learn
japanese
i bought my niece bought a book from
sent to me here i never opened the books
once i opened it and i didn't have a
time
yeah so i didn't study yet but i have a
book
but you said you want to do you want to
learn the guitar again